she is
do you hear mr. in Chamonix
just started and you lift your hand so
the first problem is is staccato the
second problem is there's a gap okay so
she goes and let's make another problem
go yeah I'm overextending right I'm
pushing into you so as you go I'm just
wondering you see that difference I
don't get stuck on her key or anything
cuz I'm just fitting perfectly letting
her go up
[Music]
you hand up the arm all the way up like
who is
so do you help licenses it's very light
okay go hey so since he's Nagi I'll move
wherever I need you so if you can't get
if you can't get up from Keita then just
get up how you can okay and I do what I
do so I can get up one by one as he goes
like he'd get up and he said if I want
whatever this time he's gonna get up and
move backwards and I'm gonna keep the
same feeling you go ahead and walk
backwards that's it got the idea
you're gonna walk backwards
so as I do as I do the drill I'm not
going like this yeah I'm jumping you
back right and at the same time all
right I don't have my gaps I'm going to
stay connected entire time
okay try it
either these hands gonna come up again
like the first trip okay this time I
bring my second hand in the same
so my hand is up it's already moving
there DC and it fits perfectly in there
it's not going at the beginning
underneath it's not getting there at the
end this is a harmonious uniting the key
okay so the UK is not trying to stick to
me they're helping me by they're doing
their assigned roles okay so I might
give them another side role it's gonna
be this one okay so I'm gonna go up I'm
gonna make sure I get that to see how
we're stuck there cuz you're lifted too
hard there okay I go I want to give this
opening at the top I want I want to eat
them so you can inhale all the way up
but definitely the top I want you to
make you're evil all the way under
inhalation okay so here we go it looks
like this
okay so he goes by doing the same thing
he nails at the top and you'll feel the
opening yeah
I started to move my stance other angles
we go
this me comes out
Kate tried well try different teeth yes
and he probably won't do it but we'll
all do the same side forever
Hey
you can see
okay they're all doing the same to me
well that she ran out of air
all right there feel that see how you
can stay because you're tense I see that
I want you to be able to feel to feel
that because that's your energy that
you're trying to detect okay
so we're gonna do a lot of rotation and
what it is is he didn't get put his hand
do you see that he held himself good so
everyone else let the in-space go and
then they found a young space here and
you didn't put your hand there
you found a young spacing here you get
that I just want you to feel whether
whether he's going to keep extending
right or whether it's not and if we're
getting too many good kids that are
falling onto this dog space then then
try it trying his response and see if
your noggin can pick up on it okay
just try that usually in Europe in your
training and he goes fast and hard to
stomach I can feel that okay because of
the slowness people weren't doing it as
much but the fear of the falling causes
them for flex okay so let's just put
that in the back of our heads but I can
also make him not want to come back this
way
by filling this with my body like this
okay he wants I could feeling if he
wants to go back to that comfortable
even though I mean his father
do you understand okay so when he goes
in this time then I fill it in like this
and you're gonna have that in space much
much more okay so last time I was having
you just bring your knee this way
this way a combination of the standing
drill as he goes so up on you go and I
fill this in that's all we're doing when
filling it just looking at that one step
in fill your body
okay let's cut okay he's he's he goes
and I step into the space likes and so
you see how I stayed connected but his
arm went dead right so I can move in all
the way so if it will do that he handed
me a pen see that the key musubi
happened on our bodies
you see you know k do that same key
musubi right if I I have the same option
well you see and then getting up then it
won't be any space so Ezekiel okay when
I come up and he fills that space right
he he gets stuck there right whether
it's my brakes on the ground or my
trainee that goes hey don't lose
connection and go like this because
you're gonna go from the frying pan into
the fire I see so I'm here he goes
do you guys understand that you can be a
fulfillment okay so then we can continue
to work that key musubi of eco whoa so
right here do you see there's that
there's that wall there's a wall right
there then he's protecting so I can't if
I stand up he'll follow me though my CC
if I try to go in here I'm going to run
into that okay so their energy key
musubi harmonizing yin and Yan goes
around you see then then watch I'm gonna
let go of this just watch what happens
okay there we go
one
still blend right come around that
energy point then it'll fall down and
you follow it
follow in sir
there it goes energy I can feel it
you go around it then it falls down
follow it down without losing connection
go around it let it fall
don't lose connection so different than
this drill is this do you guys see that
difference okay
okay try so key musubi happens all the
time right
he goes you can see in here please
there you go so there I stay connected
right now let's see how you you have
that all right okay so look I'm gonna go
around all of this don't you don't have
to do anything for me
deep am i grabbing you no I'm not
grabbing you I'm just gonna go around
all of it you see then I'm just gonna
wait and I'm follow yeah I thought this
is not how you gotta do an armbar
someone that's not how you're gonna do
our part but the concept of key musubi
is there there is a way where I can
unite energies and get all this to work
I don't ever have to grab him and I can
move matter by moving energy that it's
just basic basic physics he goes
there's where we get stuck that's fine
that's telling me go around it then look
just wait
clarification I don't wanna lead in
straight okay so we're not when I go up
and remember I was like good yeah that's
not how you would do it on Clark
he musubi isn't a good arm bar okay I'm
just saying that I might take different
steps okay so I go right and he goes all
right stay there now shove my arm down
to the ground sergeant go go you could
get go ahead and put it down if you want
go do you see so you're you're uh you're
supposed superficial geometry fulcrum
lever and all you think it is do you get
what I'm saying so any anywhere so when
he goes he gets me down there right
right he goes to shove it down oh and I
hit that I can now change this fight see
that the fight is gonna change so
whether I come here to kick them in the
face right or whether I go to ground I
can't have that opening so even you go
faster cool even as I'm doing this right
go ahead
right resist
resist as hard as you want okay you see
you see that different so go back so he
resists as hard as he wants right I'm
still going to take that angle do you
see how how I did that
so whatever strange cold you you're
going to apply you're going to apply it
at those angles you can do understand
got it so that's why it's what we're
doing is going well if you take out all
your other power sources it should still
function right it should still function
so this step is very hard for you to
kill for example but if I just
[Music]
that's why so it's a little different
but what you're doing is still included
in an eco application or an armbar
application okay there are these key
musubi angles and everything that you're
doing I try it again so he's going up
I'll step up the same way but I feel a
lot more structure you see and you can
feel that and I'm going to go around it
you guys up oh I'll feel it I don't
really care about your footwork you just
feel like that's there and you'll start
to come down so I'm gonna go around it
I'm gonna yield to it and I'm gonna
yield to where he wants to just lay down
[Music]
hey Chuck
just working on a keep assuming she goes
up oh oh I haven't started moving yet
did you do you notice Thanks
oh here it comes
see
you'll feel it I want you to stick to
get the sensitivity so
[Music]
try